when I was on SNL people were always
asking me for auction items so I decided
every time a Guesthouse would come on I
get an auction item so Paul McCartney
was on I had a page run downstairs and
get the Magical Mystery Tour or you know
one of the albums and he would sign it
and then Kurt Cobain was on and I had a
page go down and get something for him
and he brought up a unauthorized
biography of Kurt Cobain so I had I gave
it to Kurt Cobain and he signed it I
didn't look at it for like a week or two
and I finally opened it up and it was
looked like a third grader handwriting
says I am not Liberace Kurt Cobain
and then Carrie Fisher was a friend of
mine and she has she was bipolar so
there was a psychology today with her
picture on the front and her about her
bipolarness and asked her if she would
sign it she signed it and I thought okay
let's be good auction item I look at
about a week later and it says Dear
Kevin you're an [ __ ] love Carrie
so I kept all those auction items by the
way you guys have so many people on the
show like who's the person that's been
on the show that you would say you were
most star-struck by music wise or yeah
well there's top three would be Paul
McCartney Mick Jagger and James Taylor
wow I've always been a James Taylor fan
I play the guitar and I've always tried
to figure out his finger picking styling
with the record I put the needle down
and it took forever so when he's on the
show I'm like oh my God it's James
Taylor and I've gone to like 100 of his
concerts I was like a deadhead for James
Taylor
and he's there and we're standing at the
craft service table where you get food
and there's donuts and he comes over and
I'm like shaken and I start talking to
him I ask him how he formed a cord you
use your pinky when you make that cord
yeah yeah I do oh damn that's too hard
for me so we're talking for a while and
he says uh you know you know I say this
a lot but I I I sure would love to get
together again you know I mean I say
that a lot to people but I I think we
should and he gave me his phone number
and a week later I go to pick him up at
his apartment it was like a date I take
the elevator up it opens up into his
apartment he's there with his jacket on
he's holding a little dog he puts a dog
down and we leave and he wants to go to
a Cuban restaurant on Broadway I hate
Cuban food it makes me sick I get sweaty
and I didn't say no though I said yeah
let's go do that sounds good so we go to
get Cuban food and we eat and we're
talking I don't remember thinking about
what we talked about and we walked back
to his apartment and now I'm thinking do
I kiss him when I get there do I hug him
where do I go am I gonna end this
and since then we kind of you know had
done a lot of things together
you know I went to Martha's Vineyard to
record his um getting ready for a tour
and um he even he shared a cabin next to
ours and Martha's Vineyard because his
house is getting renovated and he came
over
and uh he he put his song list down on
the table saying what I'm wondering what
and what songs do you think I should do
for this and I'm like holy I can't
believe he's asking me what songs he
should do and the last one was called uh
Lonesome Road walk down the Lonesome
Road which he played at Belushi's um
funeral service and I said thinking like
a comic I think well maybe you don't
want to end on a on a down note like
that maybe you know something big it was
no no I'm ending with that that one
that's mine
so I mean all because of SNL I mean he
was that was huge for me
foreign